serious question john cena edition are
these robots really in disguise hey
volkswagen talking to a lamborghini I
can see you
we know transforms P so when Optimus
honks is warning truck more easy farting
and why do transformers even have
genitals this mean Optimus Prime is bde
big dick Energon most transformers names
I get the robot with the spinning parts
is called spinister the spaceship train
is called Astro tree so what's the deal
with Huffer and thrust
[Music]
why does the Transformers logo appear in
the car they transform into is it a gang
tattoo yes I love doing bumblebee let's
get real what are we doing a beast war
spin-off I'm waiting for Brest force in
the future is everyone gonna wear a
jumpsuit with their initial on it can
they come with jorts
[Music]
there's Optimus Prime do for fun have
any hobbies is it okay that I think
blackarachnia is superhot is it okay
that I think tarantulas is super hot
doesn't mean I got a thing for robots or
spiders no judgments either way
the Transformers do it Oh birds and the
bees
why are transformers always hanging out
with kids you guys are a war just get a
sitter so you have no idea where he came
from no idea how is Charlie so confident
that bumblebee as a boy robot the gear
shift the antenna was it the tailpipe
kind of a dick move by Optimus Prime to
have the Autobots retreat to a planet
with 7 billion people
why not regroup to a planet of toasters
or something brave little cannon fodder
what toy exact thought the best way to
sell new toys was to traumatize kids by
brutally killing their old ones the I
still get nightmares prestonby's
Wheeljack who did canopy piss off
you turn into a helicopter you turn into
an sr-71 you turn into a dinosaur you
turn into a tent the film kind of
implies that Decepticons invented the
internet so is Al Gore what does it feel
like if I transform into a car someone
climbs inside and drives me does it hurt
does it feel good comrade Astro train
ride up to transformers Dream of
Electric Jeeps
thanks for hanging out John Cena
[Music]
subscribe
you